salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
vous reconnaissez sûrement l'endroit
nous sommes aujourd'hui à our Brava on
est en compagnie de Quentin de jade mais
aussi et vous vous y attendez sûrement
parce qu'on a fait beaucoup de vidéos
avec eux de Dani et de Vim qui sont
venus des Pays-Bas jusqu'en Espagne
aujourd'hui donc on espère que le spot
va leur réserver des surprises on a
trouvé ici des munitions de fusil à
pompe enfin des munitions de fusil de
chasse plutôt on a trouvé aussi un
silencieux de pistolet mais on n' pas
trouvé les armes so we need to find the
weapons good h il a dit qu'on espère et
et voilà en tout cas vous avez la chaîne
de de Vim qui est en description de la
vidéo n'hésitez pas à jeter un coup
d'œil d'habitude il trouve des choses un
petit peu mieux que
ça regardez des tas de ce briquet yes
Nice F ok c'est plus c'est pas vide il
reste quelques trucs c'est un coin sympa
pour faire du
kayak pas mal il reste quelques trucs he
là je sens quelque chose après il y
avait des gros objets aussi te rappelles
qu'on avait peut-être un peu laissé
ouais bonne bonne ch merci merci au
revoir il y a pas mal d'objets qui qui
font des bulles wou
oh on vousé chance oui
oui cool il est beau hein il est
chouette ah
Baptiste
ah quelque
chose montre
l'arrière un tube ok étonnant oui les
petits bon vous avez quelque chose ouais
j'ai un bon poids et je crois que c'est
de là que
vit c'est un piège à
poisson growinged
oui de la pour cultiver de la
oue une poubelle comme
C
on
ou clean par contre on peut la garder
pour on nto vous inquiétez pas avec un
sa on peut la garder la poubelle ouais
on peut garder la poubelle pour mettre
la ferraille ou bonne idée je sais je
sais merci ok
sympa Netto ah oui un petit couteau
sympa une Bou d'ore ok
good
c'est pas uneorme de meurtre ça mais bon
petit couteau sympa et elle est où la
mienne al là je crois que c'est Baptiste
qui me l'a piqué tiens coquin il m'a
volé ma corde il a pas fait exprès en
plus à ce moment en plus je repêché mon
avec la corde ah je moi d'abord
qu'est-ce que tu as eu un couteau un
couteau
il a pris il a pris cher avec l' salé
non mais ah ouais sympa ok ben ouais toi
aussi deuxième couteau alors dan en a
fait un d'un crime ouais peut-être je sa
pas bravo J
voà o
ok ok
ok il y a le monsieur du port qui voyait
ça et qui s'est dit mais mais qu'est-ce
que vous faites c'est interdit de pêcher
mais heureusement en fait ici on
nettoyait juste l'eau donc donc il a dit
que c'était ok qu'on pouvait continuer
donc visiblement la la pêche rien dit
non non il a dit ok ah il a dit ok ouais
ouais visiblement la pêche allément est
est légale en Espagne plus ou
moins
garage ah ouais
ok qutin
Quentin Dani a un pistolet au bout de l'
m mais faut que le gars
[Musique]
parte donc là les gars dan il a un
pistolet au bout de l' MS il a vu qu'il
avait un pistolet au bout de les m mais
il se passe un truc de dingue c'est
qu'il y a le mec du port en même temps
qui est làut faire maintenant
disc
oui
oui il est derrière le muret il est là
il
[Musique]
ok ok ok il a quelque chose oh purée
c'est un
revolver il est
cassé a qu'un
bout c'est un VI c'est un d'ordonnance
français je
crois
ok c'est rolver 1892 CIV
félicitation ça commence
bien
Nice
incroyable on VI de commencer
manufacture d'ARM de
saétienneou la seconde
partie
il a trouvé des
ressort je
pense
ouais
ouais c'est super super c'est ça je
pense que c'est celui-là de ressort
ressort d'alarme ouais bout de
ciseau le pêcher quand même mais il est
[Musique]
vide et ok alors de pêche oh il est tout
neuf
BR Fing
ok un couteau AHF
ok la fourm fa bon profit
encore non non la France partout en
Espagne Quentin je vais essayer de
chercher les autres morceaux de ce
revolver il y a le bateau qui dérive là
ils ont oublié de jeter l'encre he faut
leur
dire il y un autre qui arrive droit vers
nous ah non
demi-tour c'est incroyable comme je
pense qu'il y était pas hein quand on
est venu ah non non vu comme il est en
bon état non il est propre avec
ouais super il a réussi à remonter une
voiture de
courseum fond racing
car non
China un
peu
pr je pr oh des clés encore fait des
tonnes ici
plein de clés pas de PA tant qu'on a pas
trouvé la deuxème
partie allez on va
essayer
cool c'est le même donc a retrouvé une
autre partie du
[Applaudissements]
revolver cool
and no
no ok good F even in
Spain i'mad I got this so then you can
take take
this
i like this
one
number there is still a lot of
pcesing
il est beau ouais le couteau cout de
jade ouais il ressort bien c'est vrai
sympa aussi
en avec une petite
médaille avec un arbre bon ben écoutez
le spot commence à se vider c'est vrai
qu'on l'avait bien fait la dernière fois
aussi on a eu on a eu un peu de chance
quand même parce que je pense que ce
revolver là était pas dans l'eau quand
quand quand on l' fait la première fois
donc plutôt cool voilà pour vous en dire
plus sur ce revolver donc on pense que
c'est un 1892 alors le 1892 en France
c'est assez particulier parce que c'est
un rvolver assez puissant du 19e siècle
il a servi pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale et même encore pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale pour certains
pour certains soldats il y en aussi qu'
l' avait pendant la guerre d'Algérie
donc c'est un c'est un revolver assez
emblématique de l'armée française ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est que il était
en détention libre jusqu'à il y a
quelques temps puis il est passé dans la
dans dans les exceptions donc c'est une
des seules armes du 19e siècle qui était
en catégorie B donc interdite sans sans
licence de tir mais mais voilà c'est
super super intéressant d'ou trouvé ici
voilà c'est vrai qu'en plus avec le
canoncier ça montre qu'il a sûrement été
utilisé pour faire des braquages ou ou
ce genre de chos mais voilà donc
revolver à poudre noire allez Quentin
étoile le spot
on n'est pas en France alors on fait
encore plus attention déjà que les
Français ont pas la meilleure réputation
à la frontière de l'Espagne
mon petit
Kant voilà bétit bon appétit à tous on
va faire une petite PAA sur le la pose
de pêche àément on espère que vous avez
kiffé cette vidéo en tout cas nous on a
kiffé cette paille là et c'est le
principale quand j'étais avec eux
l'autre fois c'est moi qui ai trouvé
tous les meilleurs trucs pom et tout et
la dernière fois c'était jade aussi la
dernire fois c'était Jade et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ils vont prendre le
revanche mais bon tant mieux c'est pas
grave ça arrive et c'est le jeu de la
pêche alland allez on dit à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de
pêche alimment allez tu peux attaquer
ciao ciao